Ngozi: Hi YouTube, this is Ngozi Okonjo-Iweala,
I'm an agent director of the world bank.
I'm talking today about investing in girls
and the girls effect.
This video, a girl called Anita challenged
all of us to think of how specifically we
can help to invest in girls and make sure
that girls get the opportunity that she was
denied earlier on in her life.
I think we need to do this at every level.
At individual level each one of us alleged
to be better off can commit to try and find
a girl, a group of girls in a developing country
where they are not so privileged that they
can help to make their lives better.
You can do that through working with an NGO.
There are many reputable NGO's who are committed
to helping girls, and I'm sure you can find
who they are online.
We should do that through institutions such
as mine.
The World Bank is very very focused on girls.
We believe that investing in girls is investing
in development.
If you invest in girls, they are at the bottom,
top and middle of everything.
They can make a difference in climate change,
in population, in reducing poverty, in all
the millennium development goals that we are
so interested in.
So institutions should commit and the World
Bank is committed.
We have a very good initiative; the focus
is adolescent girls in conflict and fragile
states because we believe that they deserve
tremendous attention.
If you look at most of these states, many
of the girls are not in school.
In Southern Sudan, only 1% of the girls finish
primary school.
So we are committed to change this and to
make – help the governments make a difference
in these girls lives.
So the question I have for you YouTube communities
is what are you going to do after you listen
to me talk?
After you hear the story of Anita.
After you think about the issue of girls
After you reflect on the fact that of the
130 million children out of school, 70% are
girls.
What are you individually going to commit
to do?
Thank you. I'd love to hear from you.